[Aplausos]
todas las sonrisas hablan el mismo
idioma
ya esta hora ustedes entenderán que está
haciendo un poco de nervios pero bueno
vamos a hacer esto le va a pedir que
hagamos un ejercicio
si les pidiera su mejor sonrisa en este
momento cuál sería
bueno esta es la mía
ahora aunque no conozcamos a la persona
solíamos leal a quien está al lado
derecho y a quien está al lado izquierdo
de su mejor sonrisa
ya por último démosle la mejor sonrisa a
quien tengamos atrás
jajaja
qué mensaje creen ustedes que
transmitieron en esa sonrisa que dieron
o incluso en la que recibieron
todos nos vemos igual cuando sonreímos y
en ocasiones la sonrisa puede tener el
poder de cambiar el mundo de la persona
que la recibe y de quien nada también
les presento al guapo y al casi guapo o
sea mi papá y yo
ahorita les explico el porqué de sus
apodos esta fotografía es de mis
favoritas de la infancia la quería tanto
que yo la pegaba en la ventana de mi
cuarto con el deseo de que todos los que
pasaran al frente de la casa dijeran wow
qué fotografía más bonita verdad eso era
lo que yo imaginaba pero bueno el sol la
dañó yo la repare de ahí con un poco de
cinta mi papá era polaco no porque
naciera en polonia polaco de oficio era
en costa rica el polaco es el oficio de
vender ropa casa por casa ropa y otros
artículos para el hogar yo tuve la dicha
de ir con mi papá desde niño a vender y
descubría como él con risa y con buen
trato le vendía a los clientes
los clientes de mi papá todos serán
diferentes como todos los que estamos
aquí hoy presentes todos somos
diferentes pero cuando mi papá llegaba
con mercadería nueva era como que todos
hablaban el mismo idioma todos felices
probándose la ropa y comprando ahí era
cuando yo veía que mi papá entre más
reía más vendía
hoy entiendo de que no sólo se trataba
de risa sino también de una actitud
una vez aprendida la técnica ya sabe en
la cual técnica la sonrisa les voy a
hablar de la actitud ahora quiero que se
imaginen esta escena
no les cree a jeremy usted demasiado
guapo lo que le tienen esa envidia
eso era las palabras de aliento y ánimo
que me decía mi mamá cuando yo llegaba a
la casa de pequeño triste llorando por
burlas por los defectos físicos y
complejos que tenía yo al final le
terminé creyendo a mi mamá
y es que en la vida todos ustedes y yo
tenemos que escoger y quiero que digan
conmigo escoger
todos en la vida tenemos que escoger
cuáles palabras vamos a creer si todas
aquellas que te dicen lo negativo que no
se puede que no se tiene dinero que no
se tiene cualidades que no se hay
actitudes o todas las que te dicen que a
pesar de todo si se puede al trasladar
la filosofía de mi madre a todas las
áreas de mi vida empecé a creer que
podía ser más de lo que se esperaba de
mí y empecé a sonreírle a todas las
oportunidades que se me presentaban
y adivine cuáles oportunidad se me
presentó a los 17 años conocí a una
mujer que dije yo esta es
y claro
en medio de todos mis complejos y decía
no puede ser esta mujer tan guapa
pero yo feo acomplejado por supuesto y
sin plata y no tenía muchas
oportunidades fue cuando empecé a usar
otras técnicas y otros metros y
definitivamente la sonrisa me iba a
ayudar
y es que a pesar de que si yo me hubiera
puesto a pensar solo lo negativo
probablemente nunca hubiera logrado nada
es cierto que algunos problemas en la
vida son serios lo que llamamos golpes
de la vida pero nada ganamos haciendo
énfasis sólo en lo negativo que por
cierto de golpes de la vida desde muy
temprano yo recibí un gran golpe en mi
vida que cambió todo a los tres años
tuve un accidente y un carro me
atropello la escena me dejó con un
injerto en el pie una operación en la
ingle y un ojo estrábico
crecer en el mundo sabiendo que eres más
que tus defectos físicos no es fácil el
mundo es cruel
pero decidí
darme la oportunidad de creer que se
podía ser diferente y que podría superar
esas etapas al final también soy
consciente de que mi mamá me veía con
demasiado amor por eso me había tan
glynn también soy consciente de que los
clientes de mi papá no eran tan guapos
como él decía
y al final también soy consciente de que
mis problemas eran serios
sin embargo decidí creérmelo y cuando
eso empezó a suceder los milagros
empezaron a cambiar como una gloria que
les comenzaba les comentaba ahorita al
principio cuando yo la conozco y dije yo
aquí ya está en medio de todos estos
complejos que tengo yo y todo lo feo que
pueda sentirme
empecé a crear con ella una genuina
relación de amistad la empecé a hacer
sentir cómoda conmigo y bueno el
resultado al final logré el objetivo y
hoy tenemos 15 años de casados y tres
hijos
yo sé
que al final en mi vida no todo era
perfecto
y no era que yo sonreía porque todo era
lindo
después del fracaso de haber dejado el
colegio votado
las oportunidades en mi vida se fueron
desvaneciendo por malas decisiones
sin embargo nunca perdí el optimismo de
que podía cambiar algo en mi vida
y bueno retomé el estudio y empecé a
trabajar por dicha porque dije yo ya
ahora sí voy a poder invitar a la gloria
ahora y no como una ocasión que la lleve
ahí a comernos 2006 terminó pagando el
general a ver que no tenía yo dinero
definitivamente
las oportunidades que se estaban
presentando en ese momento era de
empezar a trabajar solo que hay de
probablemente a ustedes les pasó igual
que a mí nos topamos con algunos jefes
gruñones en ambientes laborales tensos a
veces donde las sonrisas no existen pero
bueno en medio de las circunstancias
difíciles de los trabajos normales
aprendí que las mejores ideas pueden
salir de sonrisas abiertas y es que reír
es como volver a nacer quiero que digan
conmigo volver a nacer
por la risa el mundo cambia vuelve a ser
un mundo alegre bonito un lugar sagrado
por la sonrisa
la vida puede dar giros diferentes que
cambian el escenario y yo entendía que
en ese momento todo lo que yo estaba
viviendo y había vivido me estaba
atrayendo al lugar donde estaba
todo lo que hemos pasado ustedes y yo
las etapas que hemos pasado nos han
traído donde estamos hoy por hoy solo
que tenemos la posibilidad de llegar a
las etapas sonriéndoles aunque no sean
muy bonitas o sufriendo porque no
vivimos donde queremos hacemos lo que
deseamos ni tenemos lo que siempre
anhelamos definitivamente en medio de
todo eso yo entendí que estaba haciendo
algo que yo anhelaba
yo como lo explicaron al principio soy
el empresario al primer año de casado
hicimos mi esposa y yo nuestra primera
empresa y ha sido una aventura de no
parar hasta el día de hoy como decían
ahora reinventándome cada día hoy
tenemos cuatro empresas más de 500
compañeros de trabajo participan con
nosotros en diferentes gestiones y eso
nos llena de alegría dos de nuestros
proyectos apoyan al emprendedor como al
inicio mi tía nos apoyó y nos dio
consejos y motivación así ahora nosotros
apoyamos a emprendedores y eso nos llena
de alegría y de mucha emoción
yo creo que dios ese era el plan para
que tenía para cada ser cuando le asignó
su misión única y particular como a las
plantas les pide flores al cielo le pide
estrellas ya nosotros los humanos nos
pide sonrisas
yo sé bien que no puedo cambiar el mundo
pero si le puedo decir a las personas si
le puedo decir a la gente cómo cambiar
su mundo sonriéndole a la vida creyendo
de que hay una oportunidad de un mejor
mañana
es por eso que yo creo que mi familia y
sus familias y sus miembros son los que
más derecho tienen de esperar nuestras
sonrisas sonrisas de apoyo y de aliento
sonrisas de ánimo y de perdón sonrisas
que alivien las inevitables tensiones
que nos provocamos en el diario vivir en
el trabajo a mí me encanta con todos los
complejos que tenía antes jamás en mi
vida hubiera imaginado yo ser jefe de
alguien pero ahora me encanta como ahora
me toca hacer esa oportunidad me encanta
llegar al trabajo y sonreír y ver que la
gente diga y este que le pasa sabiendo
las cosas como están
me encanta que después de una carcajada
otros ya empiezan a reírse con migo el
momento terrible contable o financiero o
del cliente pierde importancia nos
relajamos nos vemos a los ojos y podemos
encontrar una solución
he descubierto que a mí mismo me hace
falta la sonrisa que doy ahora ustedes
dirán claro para esto es muy fácil
porque usted nació así pero bueno ya les
conté algunas anécdotas de mi vida que
no fueron nada agradables y que
provocaron más lágrimas
qué alegría es por eso que yo hoy
entiendo de que esto se trata de una
decisión digan conmigo decisión
esto se trata de una decisión y no de
una linda sonrisa porque atrás de eso ya
habrán notado tengo la sonrisa torcida
también
bueno esto se trata de una actitud de
todos los días
finalmente quiero decirles que a mí me
encanta cantar y los poder a deleitar en
este momento me encanta el karaoke
también pero lo hago tranquilo es que
ahorita no les voy a cantar pero si voy
a citar a coco fuck que de palabras nos
hemos cansado yo creo en ese arte
sincero y bien pensado y creo en la
sonrisa que rompe las barreras sonrío
día a día incluso en los problemas si
bien tengo momentos de desgano recuerdo
que ante todo sigo siendo ser humano
conservando mis principios y mis ideales
veo que todos somos iguales las
diferencias son solo culturales las
sonrisas son universales y es que a mí
al igual que el cantante de esta canción
la vida me ha enseñado que puedo hablar
sin palabras porque incluso a veces hay
palabras que no pueden describir lo que
estoy sintiendo lo que estoy viviendo lo
que estoy
finalmente ansioso del momento con voz y
lo describe una sonrisa
quiero que digan conmigo todas las
sonrisas
hablan el mismo idioma
todas las sonrisas hablan la misma el
mismo idioma y es una frase que llevo
grabada en mi corazón y también la grabé
en mi piel muchas gracias
[Aplausos]